تحول الجدل الحاصل حول مشروع قانون قوارب
الهجره غير النظاميه في بريطانيا من
مناقشه لمضمون القانون الى خلافات شكليه
تناول التعابير اعلاميه واسقاطات تاريخيه
فتغريده الذي يقدم برامج على قناه بي بي
سي والتي شبه فيها قانون الهجره بتلك خلال
ايام المانيا النازيه فجرت معركه كانت
تطويق اليها تيارات بريطانيا المتصارعه في
البدايه اوقف جاري لينك عن تقديمي برنامجه
فانسحب العديد من الصحفيين من اعمالهم في
المؤسسه اشتعلت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ولا يبدو ان هناك تهدئه من داعمي الذين
هددوا بالانسحاب من المؤسسه بسبب ما
يقولون انه انتهاك لحريه التعبير
الاشاره الى المانيا النازيه امر حساس في
بريطانيا حيث اعتبرت وزيره الداخليه ان
لها حجه لاحد في تشبيه قراراتها بالنازيين
اعتقد انه من غير مقبول مقارنه مقاييسنا
التي تعتبر قانونيه ومناسبه ورحيمه
بالمانيا في الثلاثينيات في مطرت بي بي سي
الى محاوله احتواء قرارها
اود ان ارى جاري يعود على الهواء على بي
بي سي لكن علينا ان ننتبه الى كيفيه
الحفاظ على التوازن بين الحياد وقدره
الاشخاص الذين يعملون لحسابهم الخاص على
قول الاشياء عبر الانترنت
مشروع قانون الهجره قرارا قاسيا لكن لم
يكن متوقعا اقحام النازيه في الجدل الحاصل
[موسيقى]
وفيما اعتبر البعض ان جاري تجاوز المقبول
في تعليقاته اعتبر اخرون ان قرار بي بي سي
قد يحد من قدره الناس على ابداء رايهم في
قرارات الحكومه من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربيه